also already already already also already had also
already already already already already already
[Music]
my mouth is of course a mother doesn't also have
her weapons and drugs and they burned kucharek
a play in the cast is already pointed out search
click on dry law  in front of the scoreboard and
18 took the lead to the goal made a beautiful
move on the brink of war
some roam the streets mention the
intention but I know that botafogo was
only on the sidewalk but also from the concession
tamboré timor-Leste openly the f10 the
viewing contains  60 in december
im warning level the warning in this vein
of the breeze in guaratiba friends you are
in the greatest expectation in ours but
we won out
it was not the first nor will it be even it was
good but it still goes once like it to be
tchan tchan tchan  tchan tchan tchan
tchan tchan media since according to the law it
doesn't represent so much drinking asked him
then stuffing from a lady that I arrived
as well as the legacy of bm also doesn't leave
the role of jacqueline silva who wants to
explode in the debut game
n  in giving back two young men in the hands of
guard abel braga it will be cool dribbled
put water in the place index closed the
final series of the gaucho left
alone you know better the chicago bulls
that beat the champion